the word the is canceled
according to the Associated Press
the AP which through its style book that
sets the tone for a lot of Journalism
and public writing has become more and
more woke in recent years the AP says
quote we recommend avoiding General and
often dehumanizing the labels such as
the poor
the mentally ill the French
the disabled the college educated
instead use wordings such as people with
mental illnesses
and use these descriptions only when
clearly relevant
as a style point this is bad writing
style
because a general rule in writing is it
is better to use fewer words than more
words cut out unnecessary words close up
space and generally speaking your prose
will improve political correctness tells
you to use lots of extra needless words
to to use euphemisms instead of clear
language and confuse everybody
but clear writing says be succinct be
concise be precise
the AP also doesn't follow its own
advice Ezra Levant over at the rebel
pointed out that the AP has regularly
referred to the unvaccinated probably
because it wants to dehumanize the the
unvaccinated but you're not allowed to
use those labels for anybody else and
everyone's covering this as an example
of political correctness run amok which
in part it is but there is something
deeper going on here behind the move to
take away these group categories the
poor the disabled the college educated
and and it's it's something that infects
it's a it's a mind virus that has
infected the left particularly but it
has infected the right as well which is
that this is a consequence of liberalism
this is an attack on group identity per
se
this is a logical extreme of the liberal
idea that we are all fundamentally
individuals not members of a group
I know that a lot of conservatives and
self-described conservatives
particularly of the last 50 years
have grounded their political views in
individualism but that is not a
conservative idea that is a liberal idea
you could say well it's more of a
classical liberal idea some people would
say it's actually much more of a modern
liberal idea the classical Enlightenment
liberals who talk about the sovereignty
of the individual or the modern
Progressive liberals who talk about how
how we have ownership of our body and if
we want to chop off our body parts
that's all right because we're
individuals we're we can't be defined by
our social mores or our laws or our
customs or even our families no by golly
where we can't be defined even by our
biological sex no siree we're
individuals well all that obsession with
individualism that is a lib thing the
conservatives
believe with the Ancients with Aristotle
with Christianity with the greatest
thinkers of all time that man is not
fundamentally individual but man is a
social animal man is a political animal
that we find our identity in society
with other people
that we find our our identity
in our families in our communities in
our duties and our obligations and our
role in the world
the French
the college educated
the disabled
suggests that people can be
categorized in groups
obviously that's true obviously there
are distinctions between groups of all
types of groups
the Liberals don't want to admit that
they don't want to admit that they are
that there are such things as group
characteristics group behaviors group
dynamics but obviously there are and you
see it reflected I mean this is the
entire point of my book speechless
controlling where it's controlling Minds
which is available now number one
National bestseller where is it guys get
on the stick okay fine good grief we got
producers sleeping over here today this
is the whole point of my book speechless
is that
the way that the libs win the culture
most effectively and most consistently
is not by passing big laws and not by
having big flamboyant campaigns it's by
subtly changing our language to make us
accept their incorrect premises before
we even begin a debate
so if we say okay we're not going to use
the anymore to refer to people we are
accepting the premise that people are
fundamentally individuals that groups
have no uh
shared characteristics that groups are
not a a real and politically
Illuminating category but of course that
is not the case speaking of Journalism
great story right now out of BuzzFeed
that has has really
proven old nylstradamus more and more
correct every day this week which is
that we we started off
talking about how
AI passed a business school test
Business School exam
that was the big headline an AI chat bot
passed a Wharton Business School exam
Wharton is probably the best business
school in the country and I said you
know it's not just going to be business
school you're going to see this for
lawyers you're going to see this for
doctors what happened the very next day
headline the AI chat bot
passes or gets very close to passing bar
exams and medical licensing exams
okay and I said the takeaway from this
is that the elites are going to tell you
that Automation and artificial
intelligence and Technology that's going
to get rid of lots of jobs it's going to
render whole segments of the population
useless the way that someone like Yuval
Harare and and others associated with
World economic Forum describe this as
they'll say oh these useless people
these blue-collar workers these
unskilled workers we're just going to
apply them with drugs and video games
make them go away because because
technology is going to make them
irrelevant and I said that's not true
and some limited cases that that might
be true but the real people that
technology will render jobless
it's actually white collar workers it's
actually managers who would go to
Business Schools actually accountants
it's actually some lawyers some doctors
for for certain basic programs and now
we're finding out that the people who
need to go learn to code or go get
another job it's going to be journalists
because BuzzFeed
is just announced that
it will start using artificial
intelligence
to create content not just to curate its
page and algorithms but actually to
create the articles that you like look
at on BuzzFeed our industry will expand
Beyond AI empowered curation feeds to AI
powered creation content AI opens up a
new era of creativity where creative
humans like us play a key role providing
the ideas cultural currency inspired
prompts IP and formats that come to life
using the newest Technologies
the the coming
Industrial Revolution we sometimes hear
this from the world economic Forum types
Cloud Schwab he'll say via in the force
Industrial Revolution
and this is supposed to make all of us
you know unskilled useless people uh the
the regular the hoi polloi who don't
prance around the alpsa Davos this is
going to make us all irrelevant
if there is a coming
Industrial Revolution that throws people
out it's going to affect the
white-collar people and they're going to
have to learn to code or
learn something else the rest of the
show continues now we've got a lot it's
fake headline Friday I need your help in
in sussing out which are the four real
headlines which is the fake headline and
also
buddy of mine is coming on the show very
briefly to talk about his new movie
that's coming out because Greg Perot is
the star of the new Left Behind movie
and Greg Perot
he's got a lot of great credits so I'll
wait until the member block but head on
over the movie uh premieres this weekend
it's going to be a huge Smash If you're
not a member already go to dailywire.com
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign